rapide et furieux 7 le box-office est
ouvert notre équipe notre monde tourne
autour d'eux
Dominic - tu ne sais pas que tu es sur le point
c'est un film avec de vrais enjeux émotionnels
nous sommes chassés traite avec l'amour
loyauté pour la carrière des thons I  Je vais le faire,
ce sont des thèmes qui ne sont pas
abandonnés quel est le plan du chien une dernière balade
quand vous arrêtez d'avoir avant qu'il ne fasse
plus de dégâts à notre famille ici,
vous savez que c'est un beau témoignage de
ce que ce chiffre est devenu ceci
il s'agit de ma famille alors je suis prêt à
rencontrer mon créateur
êtes-vous rapide dans Furious 7 la billetterie
est ouverte réservez vos billets maintenant